the hype is real just a few hours ago
for WebM clips are from software's
leaked Idol project beast surfaced
online it shows our new representative
character a seriously badass van Helsing
styled protagonist fighting through and
exploring his grim surroundings let's
take a little bit more of an in-depth
look the first clip our protagonist
walks through a gate shotgun at his side
cut to a brief glimpse of a towering
castle crows in the air men tied to
poles and scraggly branches reaching
into the sky another cut to the bound
men then a close-up of one who is in the
rotten state of something that only just
looks distinctly human next clip our
protagonist runs through a small valley
with the same freshly fallen leaves that
are common in these clips another thing
you'll notice are the mountains in the
distance in this clip and the one before
it you feel really drawn to a distant
objective that's constantly in view cut
to a combat sequence our protagonist
slashes with his right hand weapon which
is a strange tool comprised entirely of
a blade and a handle along the entire
length of the blade later in the clip he
throws the weapon out to his side and
extends the blade we see soul style
combat with a heads-up display lists'
lock-on a back step and singular
animations torches make a return but the
animation on the torches in particular
tell us that it's unlikely that this is
just DLC for Dark Souls 2 the most
notable thing is that we see the shotgun
firing hitting three out of four of the
enemies and another thing you'll notice
is beautiful to behold ragdoll physics
they're back I miss them so much
next clip the foal gate we see looks a
little bit different to the one we see
in souls games small humanoid shapes
reach out as our own protagonist reaches
out his hand to the gate in the soul
series we always reach out a hand before
we enter a gate but the way he's
standing sideways makes me think twice
about whether he's about to face through
the gate or whether he's just
interacting with it final clip
protagonist walks slowly towards one
hell of a demon throwing his
aforementioned weapon out to the right
and snapping it to its full length the
atmosphere is very very gothic and
horrific which is a perfect fit for a
Souls game but is this a new Souls game
there's
a lot of theorizing on what we're
looking at is it a new Souls game or is
that a new shadow tower game inspired by
a few souls mechanics shadow tower is an
old from software title that didn't see
a big Western release and there's a lot
of parallels here to it the font for
project based is also very similar to
that of shadow tower and guns also made
an appearance in that game regardless
we're looking at something incredible
here the leaks were accompanied by the
text project based from software Sony
Japan studios and Sony Playstation 4
looks like it's time to pick up a ps4 if
you want more information about the
leaks then click through to my previous
episode of souls news where I tell you
more about what we've seen and why it's
more or less completely confirmed at
this point subscribe for more Souls news
as soon as it drops and I'll see you
guys down in the comments below as we
all officially board the hype train
later guys